72 heures donc serge pomerleau denis
lefebvre yves denis on se sont envolés
littéralement dorsainvil avec un petit
hélicoptère peut être on le sera
peut-être un jour piloter par le fils
qui lui-même avait fait un séjour en
prison nous on s'est intéressés donc aux
évasions célèbre est-ce qu'il y en a
beaucoup à ce que c'est exceptionnel
andré cédilot que vous connaissez bien
j'en ai des spécialistes clément
organisé de l'amafi andré bonsoir à vous
soir d'abord ça c'est un ca sort du lot
de c'est exceptionnel ce qui vient
d'arriver
oui c'est exceptionnel de façon
contemporaine ne vous dirai pas ce qu'il
ya plusieurs années dans les années 70
je peux vous dire qu'il y avait des
évasions régulièrement dans les
pénitenciers et dans les prisons mais au
fil des années à cause de l'amélioration
des conditions de détention
il ya beaucoup moins d'évasion
aujourd'hui les évasions spectaculaires
comme celles là sont rarissimes
il faut dire que les évasions qui ont
dans le moment c'est surtout on appelle
ça des services correctionnels dans ses
statistiques après sa défaite en douce
parce que ce sont souvent des détenus
qui sont qui ont des permissions de
sortir pour un soir aux trois jours et
il ne rentre pas à la prison soit ils
sont accompagnés de ganvié ou pas ce
sommet c'est des évasions pareil mais on
appelle ça des flûtes en os ok car
audrey rhin dont je prétends 2001
puisqu'il était valide a vite car au nom
de 24 ans lui c'est un fugitif dans un
sens que ça fait onze ans c'est pour ça
que c'est un coin par cinq ans intéresse
ans ont pu comparer c'est que de dave
carroll us depuis l'opération printemps
2001 les flux qui est considéré comme un
fugitif son nom est partout sur interpol
irait chercher sa chance qu'il parte
parce que c'est sur exactement 4 me
contre les positions fait la raf de
printemps de mélo qui a arrêté des
centaines de motards lui était ponot et
il est depuis ce temps lyon le 20 mai
revue non plus et la police n'a jamais
été capable de le rattraper
donc c'est un cas où il le plus lui
d'autres peut-être une communauté
internationale s'enfuir
peut-être changer son apparence quoi
carole les derniers les dernières fois
qu'on a entendu parler d'huile à 7 en
2000 je vous dirai en 2012
son nom est ressorti dans les médias
2012 quand on a arrêté michael la joie
ce matin ses collègues un autre élan 12
mai au panama cette fois doit donc lui
carol on a donc semble-t-il selon les
dernières informations il s'est promené
d'un pays à l'autre ils étaient les
talents d'amérique du sud
on pense qu'actuellement sera peut-être
au mexique selon des documents officiels
bon les cas où deux ans les gens creuser
des tunnels où on escalade et des
clôtures tout ça c'est terminé ça
faisait l'hélicoptère dia 72 heures
devient l'exception
on n'a pas vu ça au québec là des gens
qui se sont sauvés comme cela c'est
comme vous dites c'est des permissions
les gens reviennent pas ou des fugitifs
en général c'est ça depuis quelques
années il n'y a plus d'évasion spectacle
comme je vous dise parce que d'abord vos
lucien rivard à ce que les conditions de
détention sont au meilleur qu'à l'époque
on avait aussi des prises de terre à
l'époque erreur à la relier à toutes ces
mauvaises conditions des tensions là et
aussi c'est que quand tu t'es va
d'aujourd'hui les quatre quand arrive le
temps d'être libéré d'être demi placé en
libération conditionnelle
c'est un peu plus si tu t'es évadés ça
devient très très difficile d'obtenir sa
libération conditionnelle
exemple on peut avoir une libération
conditionnelle quasi automatique au
tiers de notre pain on voit jacques
mesrine donc en images là lui aussi
oui mais ça c'est de regarder dans
laquelle année ça c'est les années 70
comme vous êtes en tout il y en a eu
dans des années 70 il y en a qui se sont
évadés us avec dire avec des camions à
benne y en ad'autres cdc va des de
toutes les feux des façons imaginables
mais ses forces et ce temps là juste un
mac os dès les premières à donnacona
better you papillon ou si on a même
sorti des images de papillons donc dans
l'histoire
l'imaginaire il ya des grandes évasions
alors revenons à nos à nos trois
fugitifs la meilleure place pour eux
pour se cacher c'est les états unis
c'est le gars c'est l'amérique centrale
c'est l'europe
au départ je pense que si je ne pense
pas qu'ils aient quitté le pays a
actuellement c'est ce que les nouvelles
nous disons nous dit qu'il serait encore
au québec et ce site c'est fort
plausible
l'important c'est que ce soit bien
planifiée qui avait beaucoup d'argent
il s'en prend de l'argent puis en même
temps ce que ça prend c'est un peu de
chance parce que c'est le présente le
pire de ça va être les deux trois
premières semaines faut qu'ils restent
cachés traître parce que la traque et
commencer les policiers pendant deux ans
et plus et toutes les informations qui
peuvent obtenir pour les pourchasser
donc il faut que dans le moment à plus
tard avec de l'argent sont capables de
rester à lyon en cavale assez longtemps
l'équipe nous parlait ce matin
moi je n'ai pas vu la série président
bric ont dit ça ressemble vraiment c'est
un col où la réalité dépasse la fiction
là depuis 72 heures
l'hélico le fisc et à l'est dans la même
prison à les repérer peut-être les lieux
ccc hors du commun
non non c'est clair que ça c'était une
évasion aussi spectaculaire de cette
année le cap terme ça c'est planifié
c'est planifié s'est organisée c'était
la minute près en plus ce qui est
intriguant c'est qu'il ya eu et plus
communiquer et ont communiqué les autres
parce que c'est quasi impossible
ils sont les trois dans la même que dans
la même cour de récréation en cinq
minutes l'avion tout le monde le parti
dont il faut que ça se reconnaît le
timing au monde il faut que ce soit
assez impressionnant avec des complices
peut-être puis avec peut-être l'argent
qui distribue on le sera peut-être un
jour andré toujours un plaisir on
voulait souligner le caractère
exceptionnel puis revenir avec des clins
d'oeil du passé merci à vous complaisez